[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos a cinco minutos
com hoy hablaremos sobre las
afectaciones que la pandemia está
teniendo sobre las mujeres y para tratar
este tema conectamos con el doctor oscar
franco epidemiólogo director del
instituto de medicina social y
preventiva de la universidad de berna
académico de harvard y de la universidad
de erasmo de rotterdam y nuestro asesor
científico en gracias doctor por
acompañarnos durante toda la pandemia se
ha hablado sobre como más hombres que
mujeres mueren por covite 19 pero cómo
está afectando la pandemia las mujeres
así es una cosa sería infectado de lo
que la infección del coronel es puede
producir y otra cosa es ser afectado por
la materia entre los hombres tienen más
riesgo de mortalidad y de complicaciones
las mujeres están siendo más afectadas a
niveles sociales económicas y mentales
por la pandemia ya sabíamos desde antes
de la pandemia que las mujeres ganaban
menos tenían más empleo informal y con
el cierre de las escuelas y con el
confinamiento lo que hemos visto es
pérdida de empleo aumento de violencia
doméstica y estar en esta pandemia y los
fenómenos asociados con la pandemia
amenaza con destruir el progreso que
habíamos logrado en las últimas décadas
en términos de equidad de género y de
derechos para las mujeres y
particularmente qué impacto está
teniendo de la pandemia sobre las niñas
la unesco dice que unos 2 millones de
niños no pudieron asistir a sus centros
académicos a clases y estos centros
académicos no solo son para la clase
sino dan protección de la alimentación
utensilios básicos como toallas
higiénicas y cuando los niños no pueden
ir fuera de la protección escolar están
más vulnerables al abuso entonces se
puede esperar un aumento en enfermedades
de transmisión sexual y también de
embarazos en adolescentes adultos y
particularmente sobre la población sobre
las mujeres embarazadas cómo actúa la
pandemia
si ya hemos visto que reportaba la onu
que más o menos unos 20 millones de
mujeres vieron e interrumpidos o con tus
controles de natalidad ya sea porque se
cerraron los servicios o por el temor a
ser infectados y lo que hemos visto en
los diferentes estudios es que las
mujeres embarazadas comparadas con
mujeres no embarazadas de la misma edad
tienen tres veces mayor riesgo de
hospitalización por el cob y 19 y unas
13 veces mayor riesgo de morir por el
quabit 19 y esto es porque el sistema
inmune se deprime durante el embarazo
como el proceso por el proceso de la
gestación entonces estamos también
perdiendo bastante lo que se ha ganado
las últimas décadas de reducción de más
de mortalidad materna concretamente cuál
es el panorama de nuestra región en las
américas sobre las mujeres embarazadas
las américas es una de las regiones más
afectadas por la pandemia la ope se
decía hace pocos días que más de 200.000
mujeres en esta área les hacen infectado
con el 19 más de mil han muerto y
especialmente en brasil se han visto
ahora con la segunda ola con esta nueva
variante pero se ha visto un mayor
aumento de mujeres embarazadas que están
siendo hospitalizados con complicaciones
y que han fallecido y esto también ha
llevado a partos prematuros y a
mortalidad en los neonatos
doctor y qué se puede hacer al respecto
acerca de ese panorama que se nos brinda
cómo abordar esta problemática
empezando con que muchas de las mejores
embarazadas mujeres empresas no suelen
incluirse en los estudios clínicos
entonces muchos países no han incluido
las mujeres embarazadas en los programas
de vacunación entonces es fundamental
incluirlas con un grupo de riesgo con un
grupo de prioridad en los programas de
vacunación de todo el mundo más allá de
las mujeres embarazadas es muy
importante
asegurar el acceso a servicios de
protección de salud de salud sexual y
reproductiva y también vamos a tener un
desafío muy grande desde re incorporar a
las mujeres al mercado entonces hay que
facilitar la generación de empleo
especialmente para las mujeres jóvenes y
para aquellas que tienen familia
rápidamente doctor y en qué etapa del
embarazo es recomendable hacer la
vacunación
hasta ahora no tenemos mucha información
al respecto porque no muchos estados han
estado vacunando mujeres embarazadas
pero lo que se ha visto como tendencia
es que tienden a vacunarse hacia la
segunda mitad del embarazo quizás fueron
temor a tener un aborto espontáneo
generado durante la primera mitad pero
por ahora no está muy claro y lo
importante es que sean incluidas como
prioridades en dentro de los programas
de vacunación y que se les ofrezca la
posibilidad de vacunarse si así decide
doctor muchísimas gracias como siempre y
gracias también a ustedes por estar con
nosotros que den sí porque además mucho
más impreso 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]